three again schroeder's defense is right  there pit pockets murray  here comes lebron get out of the way  when he comes flying down that lane  jokic was in the way along with others  and uh that foul with the gasal assist  denver will pick up the foul with lebron  getting two more reggie's got 15.  hey kev i hope people are appreciating  this right  i mean in his 18th season to still be  able  to play downhill to still have this  athleticism  to expand your game and become a much  better three-point shooter  but he's got to get better at that you  can't airball a free-throw  register i can't give you all that  praise and then you airball a free throw  yeah he's tired uh lebron is averaging  25 points  oh now we're gonna see the free throw  okay so  [Applause]  yep that is something you don't see very  often do you  and green had it